I was very small and I was always pushed around by bullies.
And I thought, "Hey, wouldn't it be great if I was a mighty person?"
Instead of a poor kid, I imagined I'd like to be a rich playboy and fight crime at night.
We never drew ourselves. What would inspire us to draw poor little guys?
Uncover the history and discover the secret origin of DC Comics.
Go behind the fiction...
We love comic books because we think maybe if the conditions present themselves,...
...we will be the hero of the moment.
...and beyond the legends of an American art form.
Comic books are the dreams and aspirations of human beings.
The best artist in the world and the best writer in the world,...
...they will make the greatest piece of art in the world and you know what you'll call it?
You'll call it a comic book.
Secret Origin : The Story of DC Comics.
Look for it on DVD and for download.